alors on et karina il ya un film avec
toi qui sort qui s'appelle la sont que
j'ai vu que je recommande aux gens
d'aller boire un mascara non non c'est
rare que je dise ça et là je me dis
maintenant c'est pas moi qui vais le
vendre le chat est là pour faire la
promo d'accord c'est toi qui va vous
expliquer brièvement alors c'est un fils
de dennis péri c'est un film de l'europe
avec beaucoup de chansons en gros ça
raconte l'histoire d'une europe statut
leur enfance son petit frère qui arrive
qui débattront entièrement et qui peut
pas se voit que son confrère il s'est
suicidé
donc il commence à faire une enquête et
petit à petit il va rencontrer tous les
gens qui ont tué son frère bennie donc
la veuve de son moi qui chante le titre
il y à kpn d'azur avec qui il va voir
une histoire d'amour absolument
passionnante
et puis au fur et à mesure il va
comprendre que son frère n'était pas du
tout la personne qu'ils croyaient qu'il
était et en même temps retrouvez-les
lui-même il sort le 18
et c'est un film de délibéré et je crois
que valence est un
un très bon film je rappe été mis à
vraiment beaucoup de talent c'est pas
parce que c'est parce que c'est vrai on
va te faire une petite interview à peine
dingue tu sais ce que c'est l'interview
open dames voilà ce qui te plaît le plus
dans la vie en général
en général c'est si la générosité je
pense les gens quand on les rencontre
dans la rue qui sont qui vous vous
aident à vivre ce qui vous aident à
vivre disant voilà c'est bien est ce que
tu es le plus chiant que tu supportes
bon flamand bas j'ai supporté ta peau il
ya plein de choses que je ne supportais
pas le racisme et les guerres la
méchanceté tout ce qui est ce qui est
triste parce que dans la pauvreté du
chômage
donc j'ai décidé de ne pas pénaliser
l'année dernière c'est celle qui a fait
le plus grand score d'image que je veux
quand tu pleures ce mardi alors le film
blade a préféré faire le lit pas là sont
parce que je suis lente
c'est toujours le prochain titre mais
c'est lequel il a préféré bon alors je
dirais il se trompe pas c'est oui ce que
je ferais pas d'y aller
non je dirais qu'ils font est le plus
beau flanc le film bat nancy king of web
présenter direct à fait légitime
je suis contre la mort si le jour où
j'ai rencontré ce metteur en scène j'ai
pu me casser une jambe sur été aussi
bien
ah non ça se voit non fumeurs d'entre
nous l'a assez le pire c'est peu
il ya la paix il y en a plusieurs
lancers
on avait tous des trucs pourris faudrait
qu'il soit mort dans des caisses que
j'ai vraiment fait un film qui me gonfle
est complètement bon mélange fait très
méchants médias le je veux dire
mais des nuages ça c'est un film de jean
luc godard aussi mais vraiment je laime
directeur puis c'est de jouer dans à
bout de souffle à tout petit rôle oui
parce que j'ai rencontré il m'a dit une
mademoiselle il faut déshabillez moi
j'ai dit monsieur je ne mets des
habitants je suis reparti trois mois
plus tard j'ai reçu un télégramme il m'a
dit mademoiselle cette fois ci c'est
peut-être le rôle principal a alors
maintenant on va passer aux choses
intimes
je vais pas y couper tu vas pas ici on a
le droit de rêver à l'or dont il va
mettre de côté denis denis berry parce
que je veux dire bon hein c'est ce sera
un peu qu'elles aient calé le ténor
l'homme que tu as préféré par dennis b
alors si tu veux je te donne la liste
mais je compte sur toi pour être honnête
dans maps moi je vais bien tes suite oui
il ya des gens qui se marient ils ceux
qui ne se marient pas moi je me suis
presque toujours marié avait déjà
corrigé
j'ai été mariée c'est vrai quelques fois
mais j'ai pas tellement connu
des hommes il n'y a pas tellement par
exemple n'était pas marié avec lui non
mais c'est évidemment j'ai eu quelques
âmes en commun non mais ça quand on vend
comprends mais je veux dire tu as quand
même eu une aventure avec jacques perrin
c'était même si c'est vrai ça c'est pas
lui avant qui avec moi aussi un abbé
s'il était là on fait la même chose la
rassure toi là là on ne fait pas de
quartier
alors jacques perrin maurice ronet
pierre fabre daniel duval j'ai pas dis
moi ton préféré jean luc godard on le
sait dit moi mon mari tiny de libérer tu
veux m'en sortir
non bon bah tu remplis qu'est ce que tu
me ranger pack tout cas marie
merveilleux et on est très complices et
tout va bien et on va faire plein de
trucs pour en revenir à godard qu'est-ce
que tu préférais chez lui mais il avait
derrière ses lunettes noires ses tripes
qu'est-ce-qui l'émission s'appelle comme
ça mais il avait un très beau regard
quand il n'avait pas ses lunettes noires
pas facile parce qu'ils avaient mais je
crois que c'était facile n'est
complètement attiré comme quelque chose
qu'on exclue on n'explique pas quoi et
puis bon ensuite ça a été
histoire d'amour bouleversante tous les
cas pour moi et puis il y avait des
hauts et des bas bien sûr comme
justement lors mais dans les eaux les
passions c'est une très bonne
enchaînement ce que tu supportes et pas
chez lui il ya bien un truc que tu
sortais de chez lui ces absences
voilà j'étais tout le temps seul et a
dit une fois dans une interview tally
peut-être mon intelligence n'a pas su se
mettre à mon niveau c'est à ce niveau
c'est terrible de dire des trucs pareils
j'étais quand même une enfant rejeté se
dire et c'est pas été pourquoi l'école
consacré d'ailleurs voie longeant le nom
ce qui fait que quand même j'avais au
départ
pas beaucoup de cultures donc il m'a
tout appris jean-luc aussi juré j'étais
à la fois sa femme et ça j'étais aussi
comme une enfant parce que bon
professeur oui exactement
maintenant ce que tu aimes le plus sans
toi à moi en toi à moi même pantois mais
je n'ai même pas t il y avait un truc
que tu aimes bien un pense que je suis
plutôt et pas j'ai pas trop mauvaise
ouais
est-ce que tu m as devant toi simple
qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy en toi
ton avis qui a fait craquer tous les mac
quoi c'est quoi
mais un peu le savoir-faire des filles
le savent ce genre de choses peut-être
que c'est très disponible quand même
bien
est-ce que tu as le moins sexy le 10
sport ne rend pas compte parce que la
seule femme pour moi au monde qui était
vraiment sexy money et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou